6 31 so are you headed to grandmother's
house for the holidays is the
grandmother's house flying to you
potentially possible either way if
you're flying around for the holidays
get ready for a big travel rush yeah
thousands expected to uh hit the road or
well i guess the sky in this case hit
the sky hit the travel plans bianca
holman joining us live at harry reid
international airport and
there are some things folks need to know
bianca
most definitely and that's first the
first thing they need to know is check
the status of your flights not only for
those departing but if you're expecting
people in town matter of fact we're
looking here at the flight boards and
we're able to see that there is an
arrival that was cancelled from spirit
airlines from atlanta and also one from
tampa that was canceled so again this is
something that you want to be checking
frequently all departures we've looked
at are on time or departing on time as
of right now so even with the increase
in kova 19 omicron variant cases many
people are not letting that stop them
aaa predicts more than 100 million
people will drive fly or take the train
or bus over the christmas holiday while
driving decreases your chances of being
around large clouds lots of travelers
have no choice but to fly travel experts
say pay attention to the coven 19 rates
in the location you're coming from and
the location you're going to it's
recommended to check with your airline
about change fees airlines like delta
temporarily removed their change fee
during the pandemic and of course in
addition to checking the website for
harry reid international airport as far
as those arrival departures we
definitely also recommend downloading
your carrier's
app to your phone because they can give
you those immediate updates when they
come or if they come reporting live from
haraveed international bianca holmen
live local now